[Musique]
femme srd à houdain centrale il ya un
véhicule en feu rue du grand-chemin
avait un numéro 100 je veux aussi la
perte de l'identité judiciaire du sénat
ouais je voyais
allez comme témoin pourquoi tu cours
farid pour 20 tours grand braquet
l'année dernière cinq braquages les
scandales les bagarres est assis pour
notre nouveau lieutenant contre l
incendie criminel rues des vignes
voilà ce sera de converser
les traces de strangulation sur le coup
stewart
vous avez vu quelque chose comme j'ai
dit à vos collègues
j'étais en train de dormir vous vivez
seul ici confie dont 10 en or c'est la
politique des soucis avec des jeunes
estime mehdi d'un titre mais on peut les
reconnaître
j'ai 1 46 ans on si je reconnaissais je
dirais pas y avait le premier sécession
tu fais notre petite fortune quoi brûler
une maison ces agréments mai soit été
marqués sur puis je lui parle je n'ai
pas brûler la maison
vous avez des suspects pour la maison
brûle les doigts ça commence vous êtes
toujours vous si un suspect kouba où les
noix sont toujours tu n'es pas notées
sur les résolutions de peinture noire
ici tu maintiens l'or alors maintient
l'ordre
c'est pourquoi faire que vous me garder
on se parle un petit peu denses fidji on
pourrait entretenir avec les allez pas
me croire
avec trois côtes de thongue autres
essais comme que claudia va venir
j'ai dit ce que je peux vous dire tout
ce que j'ai vu tout ce que c'est